[Music]  life is a road straight and narrow  stay on the road and it will take you  safely home  but make a wrong turn  and you will meet the darkness  [Music]  the detectives here she's going to be  taking over  [Music]  i'm certain i know you from somewhere  i don't think so  come on stay and play  [Music]  look i have a marriage to protect  you're afraid i'm gonna expose you to  your wife  it wasn't a robbery can you think of  anyone who might want to harm you  friends family  a woman you screwed  and discarded  [Music]  this wasn't part of the plan  did you do it did i do what  i am not a murderer  i don't believe you  i made one wrong turn  [Music]  and it cost me everything well then you  shouldn't have come to vegas  [Applause]  oh god nothing's easy with you  [Music]  [Music]